Річний обіг фірми BAEST - майже 40 мільйонів євро.
Чеське родинне підприємство спеціалізується на продукції зі сталі.
Зокрема ось таких посудинах високого тиску.
Майже 80 відсотків продукції
бувається у країнах Євросоюзу.
Власник фірми Франтішек Куловані не уявляє собі Чехії без ЄС -
у такому разі його бізнес за один день спіткав би крах.
Ми інтегровані у міжнародні мережі.
І лише завдяки членству в Євросоюзі ми маємо величезні переваги.
Але вже на центральній площі Бенешова -
міста, де розташоване металургійне підприємство,
можна почути протилежні думки.
Особливо у провінції ставлення чехів до Євросоюзу
вельми критичне.
Так, ми у ЄС. Не знаю, що нам це дає.
Ну, в цьому питанні я 50 на 50.
Не думаю, що це добре для нас.
Було б краще, якби ми вийшли з Євросоюзу.
Опитування німецько-чеської торгово-промислової палати показує:
83 відсотки іноземних підприємств
та навіть дві третини чеських
занепокоєні розмовами про CZexit.
Деякі іноземні фірми за такого розвитку подій
негайно пішли б з Чехії.
Поки у Чехії не буде нового стабільного уряду,
який чітко відстоюватиме Європейський Союз та членство в ЄС,
ці дискусії триватимуть. А це отрута для місцевої економіки.
Це змушує бізнес нервувати.
Популістські партії у чеському парламенті,
які набрали більше голосів на минулих виборах,
вже вимагають референдуму щодо членства в ЄС.
Результати такого всенародного опитування –
абсолютно непередбачувані.